Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number.
That number is 2192. David P here is
a furious Trumpist caller who sounds like
she really wants to speak to the manager.
Speaker 3: Who do you think you are? You know, you
pompous ass calling MAGA people mentally ill? You
know, that's a real stretch. You know, you got
to get off this stuff. Who do you think you are?
Speaker 1: Nobody. Yeah. So, again, listen, I
have never said. All MAGA people are mentally ill,
but I've interviewed enough of them and our
correspondents have interviewed enough of
them to know that some of these MAGA people are
mentally ill and the manifestation is an obsession
with Trump and Trump paraphernalia and Trump
gear. Others just are ignorant about politics.
Others are selfish and greedy, and they identified
that Trump policies would be good for them. It's a
combination. Who am I? I'm just like you. You have
an opinion and I have an opinion and we express
the opinions. It just might be that more people
are listening to my opinion than yours. But who
am I? I'm just a guy. That's it. We have a great
voice. A bonus show for you today. Has the world
made progress on climate change? Like all of the
years now of rallies and marches and provisions
and agreements, have we made what we can call
progress on climate change? We will discuss based
on a new report. Secondly, New Zealand is going
to vote on whether to lower the voting age to 16.
What do we think of it? I will tell you and we
will talk about the rising cost of Thanksgiving.
And I will again advocate for ditching the
turkey and doing two or three beautiful chickens,
potentially. Spatchcock. I know. I know.
I will address that on the bonus show.
Sign up at join pacman dot com. Don't miss it.
Coupon code 24 starts now. Gets you a discount.